JULIE GILHART: Thank you.
So Tess, I have to preface
this to say that when I first
met Tess, I was a
very hungry fashion
director, looking for talent.
And I was obsessed with
finding the best talent first.
And so rumor had
it that there was
someone who was doing production
for fashion shows that
was, in her spare time,
obsessively sewing things.
So in the meatpacking
district-- I
think that's where I first
met you, in the meatpacking
district, before the meatpacking
district was the meatpacking
district-- I went to
her studio, and I did.
I found this girl, and
she was obsessively
sewing at a sewing machine.
But when I say obsessively, it
was, the crux of her collection
was-- or there wasn't
even a collection.
It was just shirts.
And she was obsessively,
like, sewing
on the shirts' top stitching.
So in essence, you
had a shirt that
just had all these crazy
zigzaggy lines on the shirt.
So it looked very crafted.
And it was very
expensive, but very cool.
So I guess my first
question is-- and I never
thought about asking
this-- but what
possessed you to do
that in your spare time,
and how it led you to the--
I want to say indie brand,
but you're not up there in
the "lights, camera, action,"
I always like to say.
You're very, like,
steadfast and artistic
and doing your own thing,
and have garnered, actually,
a lot of respect in a
very-- without having
to shout your brand name.
So what inspired you or
possessed you to start that?
TESS GIBERSON: I knew I
wanted to have my own company.
So I was actually doing
the show production
to support building
my own company.
But I wanted to do it in my
own time, in my own pace.
So I was working with
the show production
to make enough money,
so then I could take off
two to three months at a time
to develop the collection.
So I always knew
in my head that was
my end goal was to
build my own company.
It was always just like, I
wanted something of my own.
But my way of doing
it-- at that point,
I wanted to make
it very-- because I
had been at Calvin Klein.
And I had seen things
on a bigger scale.
And I had seen
things where it was
very-- everything was very
refined and very clean and very
modern.
But I wanted to make it my own.
So when I started working
on my own collection,
it was all about having this
personalization with the pieces
and really, really
making my own mark.
So that was my feeling,
but it was also, literally,
I was making my own
mark by making the mark
making that I was doing
on every single piece.
And in the beginning--
I mean, I think
I just wanted to
experiment, and to really
push myself as much as I could.
Because I knew at a certain
point, it would be more public.
And at that point when I met
you, it was still so personal.
And I could do anything.
And I hadn't revealed
it to anyone yet.
And I remember-- I mean, this is
stuff they always tell people.
Julie came, and she had me
come up to the Barney's offices
and said they wanted
to place an order.
And at the time I
was like, I really
don't think I can take an order.
I just don't know if I'm
ready to expand that much.
Because I was just
selling to one store
and making one of a kind pieces.
And Julie had to-- actually,
she took me aside and she had
to really convince me that
I should take the order
for Barney's.
But it was really--
honestly, Julie
was the one who got me
started, who kind of just
got me into making
the production,
following the deliveries.
And I think I did it
for two more seasons
when I was working
part-time on my collection.
And then after that,
I just did full-time,
and then I started just full-on
doing my own collection.
JULIE GILHART: It's interesting
because there's so much support
for designers now, in terms
of mentorship and grants
and money and all
kinds of things.
And then, there wasn't.
But it's really interesting.
And maybe you can comment on
this, because in thinking, I've
been developing
designers my whole life.
And so the really great talents,
like the Nicolas Ghesquieres,
the [INAUDIBLE] the
Olivier Theyskens,
those people didn't have
any of this support.
Now I can't say that today
there is that caliber out there.
So the only thing
I can think of is
it's the way that
we're doing things.
But I'm not sure--
I'm not a designer.
So I'm wondering what you think
of what you were doing back
then, because how you
describe that is exactly
the same way that Olivier
Theyskens started,
Alexander McQueen started.
That it's very
much more concerned
about the craft of the
clothing, rather than
the commerciality
of the clothing.
And it was a very
personal thing.
So I'm wondering, what are
your thoughts about that?
TESS GIBERSON: I
think when I started,
it was-- I left
Calvin Klein in '98.
So I spent from '98 to 2001 just
kind of incubating it myself,
just developing it.
And I think back then, the
only way to make it happen,
I wanted it so badly.
And it was just out of passion.
And there wasn't any CFDA,
Vogue fund didn't exist.
That wasn't until,
I think, 2003.
It was just, there was a
community of other designers.
And we supported each other.
And it was through,
I think, peer support
and just-- I knew
inside what I wanted.
JULIE GILHART: What did
you want most, though?
What was it that
you wanted most?
TESS GIBERSON: For
me at that point,
it was just the
personal expression.
I wanted to do
something that was me.
I wanted to put
my own vision out.
Now I think about a company.
At that time, I wanted
to develop my own vision,
and I wanted to express it.
And I knew-- I've always
been very organized,
so I did things in
an organized way.
But it was about having
this personal expression.
JULIE GILHART:
That's probably why
Calvin-- working
at Calvin-- I mean,
I can kind of see a creative
person working there and seeing
how it's done on a mass
scale, but that you
would want to do
something that was yours.
And that's how Calvin started,
and Ralph Lauren and Donna
Karan.
I mean, it's really interesting.
But I think what's
interesting now
is all the access that we have.
Like, we have two really
amazing collaborators
that work with you.
And I think designers
have always collaborated
with people, but it's
almost a part of your--
it's a criteria in a way, like
who you're collaborating also
is reflecting on you.
Because everyone's
collaborating.
TESS GIBERSON: I went to RISD,
and when I was in school,
that was part of being at
RISD, was you collaborated.
You collaborated with painters
or graphic designers or textile
designers, and it was just
part of this give and take.
And good ideas always came
from working with other people.
So it was just very much the
way that I'm used to working.
And when I first started,
I worked with my husband
all the time, who's a painter.
And it was just-- we started
the first couple of collections.
We always were collaborating.
And I pulled my sister,
who's an artist, into it.
And then we started looking
out to friends who are artists.
And I worked with filmmakers,
photographers, set designers,
lighting designers.
And they were just
very close friends
who also I respected
their work a lot.
So it's just like,
I've always known
collaboration is exciting.
And when you respect
the other person's work,
it's always good no matter what.
I don't think about what
it has to look like.
And I don't second-guess it.
It's just if I respect someone's
work and I like it a lot,
it works out well.
And so when I relaunched
the new company,
that was very important
to continue that.
And so I've continued
it, even though now we
do things-- I don't
sew it myself anymore.
I don't-- it's different.
It's on a bigger scale.
But I still maintain
the collaborations,
because that's for my heart.
That's what I love to do.
And that gives me so
much more creatively.
And I met Alia, and
I loved her work.
And I asked her to do
a video and it just
continued from there.
And then through a
friend, I met Caroline.
And I loved what I heard.
And then I met
her, and I thought,
it was just an instant-- it was
just something intuitive that I
knew and we
connected right away.
And first I asked her to be
in a presentation last year.
And then I had her
do music, and then it
was natural to ask her to
do the music for the video.
So everything I do
is very intuitive.
JULIE GILHART: So you
have sort of an entourage
of collaborators.
TESS GIBERSON: I have a
lot of nice collections
of collaborations.
But they're all genuine.
They're people I
love and I respect.
And it's just such a
natural relationship.
JULIE GILHART: Isn't it
funny, because collaboration
with many designers is all
about making more money.
You collaborate with
a certain person
so that it will
sell more product.
And it sounds like
in your vernacular,
that it's really collaborating
from an artistic and respect
point of view.
CAROLINE POLACHEK: Well,
if I may interject,
Tess is actually a really easy
person to collaborate with too.
I think a lot of designers have
gimmicks in each collection,
or like maybe even a kind
of extremely intense theme
that continues throughout
their collections.
And I think in order to
collaborate with someone
like that, you feel
like you really
have to make something that
goes with the particular story
or the theme.
But Tess' work is so
open that it really
allows you to not only explore
within your own medium,
like for example, the music
I did for this video is
the kind of music I had been
wanting to make for a while
actually, but hadn't had
the right opportunity.
And the clothes presented
the perfect way to do it.
But also, I think it allows
people to do something that's,
like, peaceful and neutral
and tasteful and textured.
And it's really a great
environment to collaborate in.
JULIE GILHART: What's
the-- both of you
all should comment--
what's the process?
Like, do you come
together and say, well,
what are we going to do?
Or is it like, I have this
idea, and you expand on it?
How does that work, or is
it different every time?
ALIA RAZA: It's been--
we've collaborated together
three times now.
We've made three short little
films, or videos together.
And I think each time started
with a meeting, just talking,
lunch, whatever-- talking
about what she was working on,
what I was working on.
And then me looking
at the clothes
that she was working on that
she wanted to put in the video.
And then, just thinking
about the practical stuff,
like the music and the location.
And all of that comes
together to-- it's
not like we're working with
million-dollar budgets,
so you're not dreaming
up fantasy worlds
and making them happen.
You have to work
with what you have.
So the location, the music,
the clothes, all of it
comes together to inspire
what you end up with.
And what you end
up with is usually
a little bit different from
what the original idea is.
Like, for the video that we
all just worked on together,
I had this idea of
spiders in my head.
And Tess had this kind of giant
crochet piece in her runway
show, and it kind of
looked like a spider web.
It just all felt right to me.
And now when you see the video,
you don't think of a spider.
There's no spiders in the video.
The clothes aren't spidery.
It sounds crazy,
but the idea shifts
over time, and with each step.
JULIE GILHART: [INAUDIBLE].
ALIA RAZA: Yeah.
It's a fashion
thing, I think, and I
think if you're making films,
or if you're making art,
or whatever you're
making, it always
changes during the process.
It always changes
as you're working.
JULIE GILHART: It's interesting,
because now-- for the audience,
I'm working on this very
cool project for [INAUDIBLE]
and it's the
initiation of a prize.
And it's for talent
all over the world.
And it's for really,
really new talent.
So it's really interesting is
you have access to people that
are doing things on a
fashion level in places
like Afghanistan or Nigeria
or just crazy places
that I would never look, or
you would never have access to.
But the thing that
I look at the most
is videos, because
they all have videos.
And so you're looking at
a picture of girls or men
in clothing, and you're
reading, and you're
looking at all their facts--
the age of the designer,
and how many collections
that they've done.
But it's really the
video that speaks.
And then, addressing the
music thing for a show,
that is so much a
part of the show.
You could have a great
show with great clothes,
and if the music isn't
good, it can fall flat.
And it can actually change
your perception of the clothes.
It's distracting.
But the reverse, if you have
great music, it can also--
CAROLINE POLACHEK: It's
so subconscious, too.
It totally sneaks
in the back door.
You're looking at the
clothes, and if the music
is heavy and hard, you
don't even realize it,
but you're attributing that
energy to the clothes, too.
Like, you could show a
piece that's really dainty.
And if it's paired
with hard music,
you all of a sudden
imagine it being
worn in a really specific way.
I'm kind of new to
working in fashion at all.
And one thing that I
love that designers
say when they're designing,
is they talk about their girl.
Like, who's your
girl this season?
And at first I didn't
really understand
what they were talking about.
But they visualize a person.
And it's not just the clothes.
You can visualize
where it's going
to be worn, where she
lives, how old she is,
what she listens to.
And I think the fashion
show is the manifestation
not of just a
collection, but the girl.
And that plays back into
marketing and branding.
And that to me is actually
the most interesting aspect
of the whole thing.
JULIE GILHART: If you
ever go into a showroom--
and this happens
at a high level--
and you have them showing
you the collection,
they'll call each--
like they'll say "she,"
she's really going
to be a good seller.
Or she is perfect,
or she's my favorite.
ALIA RAZA: Who are they talking
about when you say she--
JULIE GILHART: They're talking
about garments on a hanger.
And I just like, I got
to get out of here.
I just lose it when they
start talking-- when they just
put this person.
But this is the "she" thing.
I never realized that yeah,
they talk about their girl.
ALIA RAZA: Well, I have to
say that working with Tess,
she might have a girl in mind
when she does every collection,
but she's never imposed
that on me or told me,
this is the kind of girl or the
persona or the characterization
that you should
put in the video.
It's never-- she almost
tells me nothing.
She just lets me
look at the clothes
and decide who I
want the girl to be.
And that's a great
thing about working
with people who
are more interested
in kind of the collaboration
between different artists,
rather than, like
you were saying,
on a purely commercial level
of trying to sell this image,
or this one girl.
CAROLINE POLACHEK:
Actually, when
I met with Tess to discuss
the music for this collection
for the runway show, there
wasn't any discussion
of the girl or anything
situational or social at all.
It was only about line quality.
She was showing me
Bauhaus drawings.
photographs from the '60s
of a girl inside a huge
crochet installation.
She was showing me the
drawings of the pieces.
And I went to
school for drawing,
so this totally
resonated with me.
And I just instantly heard
string, piano, digital lines,
acoustic lines,
lines out of tune.
And that music came right
out of that, and nothing
to do with-- is she a traveler?
Is she young?
What does she do?
It was just very formal and
very abstract, and I loved that.
TESS GIBERSON: And I can work
that way because of the people
I choose to collaborate with.
I'm very picky
about who I choose.
And it's always, there
has to be the respect,
and I like their work.
And then I know it's--
like I was saying before,
then I can have that trust
that it's going to be OK.
And I don't have to say,
this is how it has to be.
And I think that's what
a good collaboration is,
is where you can let go.
Like for me, I come
with, I have the idea
and I know what my clothes are.
But I don't-- I can't tell
you what the video should look
like, because I'm
not a director.
And I can't tell you what
the music should sound like.
I don't make music.
And I think it gets
tricky when you
try-- when someone who-- if a
designer tries to direct when
they're not a director, you
don't get the right result.
But if I can just let
it go, and really trust,
and then it's exciting.
I love not knowing
what it will look like,
and then it's a really cool
surprise to see the end result.
JULIE GILHART: It's
interesting because I think--
I've seen so many
designers when they start
in the business of
fashion, pre-collections
have become so important.
Those collections that are
before the runway, that
come into the stores early.
And that's actually where
you can address the more
day-to-day needs, rather than
the fantasy needs, in a way.
But it's interesting,
because usually when
a show comes around,
collaborators come in.
And what the designer told me
the show was going to be about
is never what they say.
And I think it's because
of the collaborators.
ALIA RAZA: Do you like that?
Do you like seeing a new
angle on it, or do you--
JULIE GILHART: Yeah.
I mean, I like for people
to be spontaneous and not
get stuck, and have to do that.
You have to be open,
but that probably
happens in your
process, like one idea
you have because you talked to
her, and you all start to talk,
it sort of morphs
into something else,
which really enhances
the creative thing.
And it gets you away from
the business of fashion,
and the trends, and feeling all
these subliminal messages that
come in that you feel
like, I have to do that.
TESS GIBERSON: And that's what's
so important about coming up
with new ideas and actually
finding new designs that
come from yourself.
I think that's what
collaborations really
give me, is they continue
to give me that creativity.
Otherwise, it's too
easy to get stuck
into the deadlines,
the deliveries.
That's all part of the business.
And I like that part
separately, but I also
know I need the creative
energy to come in.
And I get that through
the collaborations.
JULIE GILHART: So
it's also interesting,
because how do you tell people
about you, in terms of, like,
you don't advertise, and you
don't have a big publicist.
But yet, people-- how
are you communicating
some of these
things that you do?
And I'm saying
that in the context
of being at Barney's
when we first started.
And you'd have to
put it practically
when people got off
the escalator so
that they would see it.
And then you'd have to talk
to the salespeople a lot.
And then you have to
try and see if you
can put it in the catalog.
And so it was very basic now.
And now we have all the social
media and visual things.
So one has to choose
how they do that.
And that's also now
I'm seeing a reflection
of how you are as a brand, too.
TESS GIBERSON: We've
actually-- social media
has been great for
us, because it's
a way for us to directly
tell the story of what
the collection is, who I
am, the project I'm doing.
It's a direct
connection to customers,
anyone who's interested.
It's just like, it
reaches out directly.
We still work through PR,
working with magazines,
working online, and
also just publications.
JULIE GILHART: Traditional--
TESS GIBERSON: Traditional.
So I do both.
But the last two
years, we've really
embraced the social
media in just
being able to tell
our own story.
And that's been really exciting.
And it's just, for a
brand, for our brand
it's also through
direct relationship
with the customers--
going to the store,
working with customers,
meeting customers.
And when people wear the
clothes, they become fans.
And it's really been this
just growing word of mouth,
and directly
working with people.
And they get it.
When they put the
clothes on, they really
get what it's about.
They get what I'm trying to do.
And I don't have
to say anything.
They tell me how they
feel about the clothes.
And that's been so
exciting to see.
JULIE GILHART: I
can't help but think
that that's going to be really
important for the future,
that because you see
all these mass brands,
and they're communicated a
lot, and they sell a lot.
I don't know, how do
you all feel about that?
I mean, I'm more
attracted to something--
and today people say "luxury."
But luxury to me
is something now
that's not so easily accessible.
CAROLINE POLACHEK: Well, I
think that actually-- maybe this
is a little bit grim-- but
I do see it as a luxury,
especially in the future.
Because now that
so much production
is outsourced and expected to
happen at very cheap prices,
our idea of how much we
need to pay for a shirt,
and with the quality of
what we're going to expect,
has gotten very low.
Like maybe a girl who's like
25 thinks the average price
you should expect to pay
for a shirt is, like,
between $30 and
$50 or something.
But in order to make
something really well,
in order to source
nice fabrics--
you're not even doing something
fancy, like you said earlier.
Just something that you can wear
every day that will last you
for years, that's going
to look beautiful on you.
To do something well costs a lot
more than that, and especially
if you're working on
a small batch sizes.
And I think it's almost
similar to the model
for organic small farms
going into the future.
You can't compete with, like,
Monsanto-grown corn seed.
It, for better or for worse,
is a certain kind of luxury.
ALIA RAZA: And why
would you want to?
I feel like I don't
think Tess wants
to be making fast
fashion, and selling--
CAROLINE POLACHEK:
[INAUDIBLE] money but you
can't compete with those prices.
ALIA RAZA: Oh, yeah.
True.
JULIE GILHART: I
think it's a decision
if you want to be really big,
or if you just want to be big.
I think that we have
a-- fashion has this,
you just have to be-- to be
valid, you have to be huge.
And--
ALIA RAZA: Everybody has to know
who you are, and you have to--
JULIE GILHART: Yeah.
But I will tell you with
every single brand, that
goes into that direction, it
does lose that connection,
that personal connection.
There's always a
brand connection,
but I think the kind
of thing that you
stand for, very
intimate collaborations.
And you have a platform.
Like you were saying,
you have social media.
You can tell them exactly
what you're doing,
and that's going to be
interesting, I think.
TESS GIBERSON: And we do want
to be big, but with integrity.
Don't get me wrong.
We are very aggressive,
and we do want to grow,
but we want to do it
always with integrity,
always aligning ourselves with
projects that we believe in.
We have, like, with
my partners we all
have very core values
that we agree on.
And so as we're growing
and we're always
talking about where we're
going with the company,
it's about maintaining
the integrity,
maintaining what the
collection's about,
what the feeling is about.
And it's about
connecting directly
with the women who are
wearing the clothes.
Eventually, we want to do
men's, but right now it's
just the women.
So we're excited to
do that in the future.
But it's really making sure that
everything that we're making,
we believe in, we
would wear, we want
to see other people wearing.
There's a lot of thought
and consideration
that goes into it.
And I believe as we grow
we can maintain that,
as long as that's
always important to us.
JULIE GILHART: Do you
ever thing about Calvin?
TESS GIBERSON: How do you mean?
JULIE GILHART: Do you just ever
think about how he started,
and how his business grew, and--
TESS GIBERSON: Yeah, definitely.
That's an amazing story.
And I have a lot of respect,
so much respect for the way
that he built his company.
And that was a great
experience working there.
It was such a good
foundation for me.
And I love how
systematic, how clear,
the marketing was brilliant.
You knew when you walked
in where you were.
And it was so thorough,
and I loved that.
I loved that then and I still
love that way of doing things.
And it really had a
huge impact on me,
even though I after
wanted to do something
super, super personal.
Things I learned at Calvin, I
still work in that same way.
There's some things I
just learned structurally
that I still use when I'm
working-- the way I organize.
JULIE GILHART: Well,
we're going to have
to continue this
conversation off-camera.
But I think it's really,
really, really, really exciting.
Really exciting.
I think it's the most
exciting part of fashion.
I have to say this one thing,
because I was in the fashion
arena when they-- referring back
to the Antwerp Six, Margiela,
Dries Van Noten,
Ann Demeulemeester.
And they have those
same principles.
And believe it or not, it
was like over 25 years ago.
But they really-- and so
I think you, all of you
all have like a
really bright future.
ALIA RAZA: Those
were the designers
that, when I was
a teenager, I used
to pay attention to, and wish
I could buy those clothes,
and save up money
for those clothes,
and Margiela and [INAUDIBLE]
and Demeulemeester.
So it makes sense
that you said that.
JULIE GILHART: So thank you all.
ALIA RAZA: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you,
Julie, Tess, Alia and Caroline.
We're going to now show Tess'
video for her spring, summer
2014 collection.
And then we're going to go into
10 minutes of Q&A. If anyone
has any questions,
there's two mics.
You can line up,
and after the video
you can ask these folks any
questions that you may have.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have a
question for you guys.
My name is Michael.
I work here on the sales
side of the organization.
And I don't know why I
introduced myself like that,
because it has no
pertinence to my question.
But I guess I would just love
to hear all of your takes
on-- I think one of the things
I took away from your guys
speaking about, sort
of, your philosophy
and how you think
about collaborating,
is maybe the idea that you want
people to come to your store
or fashion or even
your video, and be
able to express
themselves through sort
of the blank canvas of your
style and of your fashion.
And when I think about the
brands from yesteryear,
all the big fashion brands
that you guys were also
talking about, I think
there's something more
about them wanting to gift
you with their perspective,
or their brand, or their
personality, or the her, right?
They want to give you the her.
They want to make you the her,
by you exchanging with them
and interacting with them.
So I was wondering your
thoughts on that idea
of the thirst for
self-discovery,
even in the things
that we purchase.
And not to be defined by
them, but to define ourselves
in that process, and
maybe how you think about
that in regards to your art,
and if that's sort of on point
or not.
TESS GIBERSON: What
I am always thinking
about when I'm designing,
I want the clothes
to become part of the
woman who's buying them.
The woman who wears
the clothes, I
want-- it's about bringing
her own personality out, not
putting on to her anything else.
But it's just like, when
I think about the clothes,
it's about feeling
comfortable, confident,
just bringing out your
own inner confidence.
It's always about that.
And to mix it however
the woman wants to,
wear it however she wants to.
That's a very big part
of actually how I design.
And I think it's not
putting something onto them,
but just bringing out
the strength inside.
And it can be really subtle,
but it's always there.
It's always something
I'm thinking about.
And I love-- I see it.
I see when the women
wear the clothes, that's
actually something
that comes out.
Because everything I do,
it's about feeling it's easy,
it's comfortable, it's cool.
And it's just about having
this inner confidence.
CAROLINE POLACHEK:
Tess loaned me
a couple looks on Trail
of Summer tour, one
of which I found myself
going back to all the time.
And not even just for stage,
but just for everything.
And on the rack, it
looks like a white shirt
with a bunch of
strings hanging off it,
and a white skirt with a bunch
of strings hanging off it.
And that's it.
But when you put it
on, it's-- I mean,
I know this kind of
idea of modular play,
because it's in
a lot of things--
in our actual websites
and furniture now.
But it really
transformed characters.
If I'd tie it one way
or tie it another way,
it could look angelic
and straitjackety
from one minute to another.
And even leaving the
strings all hanging off
was amazing for me, because
I play synthesizer on stage.
And that is the most
boring instrument
to watch anyone play in
the history of instruments.
It's a person standing
at a rectangle.
Great.
But if I have a bunch of
strings hanging off me,
every one of my emotions--
if I hit a chord,
you see it translate [BRRRAHH]
into the entire thing
I'm wearing.
And that was really
exciting too.
But ultimately, I could have
kind of laced it up nicely
and gone out to dinner.
And I think that kind of
sensitivity to the wearer
is kind of what
Tess specializes in.
ALIA RAZA: I completely
agree with you.
From all the clothes that
I have that Tess has made,
I feel the same way.
You can wear them in-- sometimes
you wear them in multiple ways
and totally make them your own.
In terms of my own
work, I don't think
that I've thought much
about-- I mean making art,
whether it's video art
or art objects-- I never
think about how somebody's
going to make it their own.
I'm just trying to
kind of impose my view,
and give somebody an experience.
But I've recently started
making perfume as well.
And I think that's similar
to clothing, in that people
wear perfume to
make it their own.
They don't wear it--
people aren't really
interested in
fragrance and scent
as something that's
imposed on them.
They want it to
become part of them.
So it's like a whole
new thing to do.
AUDIENCE: You spoke a little
bit about pre-collections,
and the role of having a
pre-collection that translates
into a full line, fall
or spring collection.
Tess, when you start designing
for one of your main seasons,
where do you start?
Like, what's step one
in your design process?
TESS GIBERSON: I
always start, actually
with a conversation
with my husband.
We've-- honestly, since college,
we've been collaborating
on just the ideas with
our work together.
I talk to him about
his paintings,
and he talks to me
about my collections.
And we just talk.
And it's through
talking and we kind of
think about different
ideas, what we could do.
So with the collections--
and I did this
with my original collection--
and even when I worked at TSE,
I worked this way.
And now it's just like talking,
and kind of brainstorming
what it could be, what
would be a fun collection
to build off of?
And what would the show be?
And I think about
what the show might
be when I'm starting
the collection.
And then I usually start with
a word, an idea, a thought.
And I take that and
I just brainstorm
words from that, and
then ideas of what it
could be in clothing,
and how can I bring those
into details in the clothing,
and how could I build up
a whole collection
around it, and then
what would the show be,
the music, the feeling?
So it's just a lot of words.
And I kind of build trees off
of words, and that's my process.
And I think I just,
sometimes I make it more
elaborate than I need to.
Because really, when it comes
down to it, it's a formula.
You kind of know what your plan
is, you know what you need.
But for me creatively
to maintain
my love of what
I'm doing, I need
to work like that, because
it's how I discover new--
how do I come up with a
new shirt every season?
I have to push myself
a little bit more.
And it's fun.
CAROLINE POLACHEK:
That makes you
think about what Alia was
saying about spiders being
a reference for her video.
Because by the time
I saw the video,
it was pretty close
to being completed.
And I did not see
anything spidery in it,
nor did I hear anything
spidery in the soundtrack.
ALIA RAZA: But I asked you to do
something spidery, and you did.
And then it kind of shifted
and turned into something else,
but it-- go ahead.
CAROLINE POLACHEK:
Well, what I mean
is there's a process
of distillation.
Like you were talking
about word trees.
And I think often, when you're
chewing on the same idea
and elaborating on it,
and trying to interpret it
across so many different
kinds of media,
you suddenly realize that
it's not the spider itself
that you were interested in.
Maybe it's the energy
of a way a spider moves,
or it's that idea
of angles, or it's
that idea of a thing
disseminating [INAUDIBLE] web.
Or the kind of quiet
predator aspect of it.
You find that there's like
a thing, a quality to it.
And you could scrap
the spider idea
and just go for that energy.
And I feel like
that's what you're
talking about when you're
going for the expanding
from a single word.
ALIA RAZA: And
that's what happened,
because it went from-- I
think when you said, what
are you thinking for the music,
and I said, I don't know,
a spider.
And you were like, OK.
And then it turned into
kind of like more alien girl
who crash landed onto a rooftop
in Brooklyn in the Apocalypse.
And all of that is
very subtle, but that's
what I was thinking of
when we were shooting it.
Yeah.
It switched.
CAROLINE POLACHEK: Don't be shy.
ALIA RAZA: Ryan?
Question?
AUDIENCE: I just had
a question, in terms
of how do you see your own
fashions evolving from what you
were, say, 10 years back to now.
Like, what's the
difference, even
in terms of-- even your art.
When you do
something, what do you
compose maybe five years
back or two years back?
How has it changed?
And what do you feel are
some of the factors that
contribute to this change?
TESS GIBERSON: The
biggest change for me is,
I always, originally I
felt this compulsion.
I had to make it myself.
And it was just like
crazy, very obsessive,
like I had to put my hand on do
every single thing I produced,
which was great in
the first two years
when I was doing limited
edition-- was like smaller
productions.
Once I started producing,
selling more and more
and the collections
were growing,
there became a problem.
Because it was like
physically killing me.
And then I had my first child.
And at that point I
realized, this is crazy.
And I have to change
the way I'm working,
because I can't keep
working this way.
I mean I would literally
be working 16-hour days.
And my husband has
his painting studio.
We had a big loft.
He painted one side.
I had my sewing machines
on the other side.
And we both just would work.
Then when we had
our first child,
we realized we
can't work this way.
And so it was at that point
I was able to step back.
And I took a few years,
I worked for TSE.
And then when I restarted,
I knew the essence
of what I wanted
to keep, and that
was having integrity,
having the creative ideas,
it was of the approach that
could keep the creativity,
keeping the collaborations.
So there was a spirit
that was maintained.
But I knew I didn't have
to make it any more myself.
Wasn't about me making the
patterns, sewing the pieces,
doing the hand stitching.
I could step back and
give more direction,
and tell other
people what I wanted,
what I wanted it to look like.
And actually, I could
be a lot more precise.
And I could get more
of what I wanted,
because I wasn't
making it myself.
And that was a really
exciting and liberating point
that I got to.
So now, I can go through
the creative process,
but I don't have to be-- it's
not as physically exhausting.
And it's a lot more fun
that it was towards the end.
JULIE GILHART: Did
you have a question?
OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Also, maybe
a selfish question.
But you mentioned menswear.
I'm just curious.
I think there are
definitely some test givers
and pieces that
I would wear now.
But I'm curious how your designs
could translate to menswear.
TESS GIBERSON: There's so many
pieces that I think already
that I do in women's that
could just be modified a little
for men's.
ALIA RAZA: Even this.
TESS GIBERSON: So yeah, exactly.
There's a lot of and the
sweaters and the outerwear.
When I was working at
TSE I was overseeing
the men's collection.
And I loved it.
I loved working-- I think
because originally I
started at Calvin Klein.
I was in the men's collection,
designing sweaters.
And there's something
about menswear
that I really like a lot.
I think that with my aesthetic,
what I do with women's, it's
not such a stretch to be
able to modify it a bit.
But I'm also not trying
to do everything at once.
I'm trying to do it the right
way, with this relaunching
the company with my partners.
We have a plan of
how we want to grow.
And we're right now just
working on really getting
everything right with
the women's collection,
the distribution, really
developing the collection,
working with the customers.
And we need to just get
a little bit bigger,
so we can hire someone else.
Because I don't want anymore
to work the 16-18 hour days.
So I know what I want
it to be, and I also
know the time I need to
allow to do it the right way.
But it's absolutely
in the near future.
JULIE GILHART: So, all men
out there, come and see.
ALIA RAZA: And then
we can do a video
with cute boys
wearing cute clothes.
JULIE GILHART: Are
all our dreams.
So thank you for hosting this.
Thank you for the introductions.
Thank you, Google.
Maybe you'll collaborate
with Google someday.
TESS GIBERSON: Love to.
ALIA RAZA: Thank you, Google.
TESS GIBERSON:
Thank you, Google.